Jesus christ founded his religion within an empire.
The Roman empire existed before and what he was talking about was all religion.
Where as Mohammad on the phone did an empire,
we forget.
Yes.
Right.
That's a very important distinction.
I mean it really,
and it made might be the crucial distinction sort of speak the crucial
distinction.
Yeah.
And there was this empire and this empire bows and decline and fell and those
who feel that they have inherited that legacy,
they want to go back to the days of [inaudible].
Yeah.
Go back to the days when his loud voice to previous and they want to do this in
the 21st century.
Yeah.
All kinds.
It's not just that you called camp on horseback and invade an existing empire.
The Byzantine like
easy and empires.
This,
he took off and you could just take things off.
It's not like that,
but they're driven.
They're convinced.
They have this legacy and they're not afraid of death.
And how is key because,
and here's why I keep going back to Dow.
All Muslim children learn that life on this as this temple.
Yes.
As your tree.
And that there is something in the here then this,
there's no point in investing in this life except in,
and they just started that.
So for the Medina Muslims,
it really becomes easy to recruit and inspire into their parents.
Muslims who have already been taught that if they've only got to work for the
hereafter problems with Islam.
And I think it was,
we understand that of course,
the basic LMS,
Mohammed Straw,
all of the Koran,
the fall of the he after all of these things and what should it mean?
And then it gets to the Dow accounts.
This is how they manage to teach young people.
How do they manage the teachable for these thousands and millions of people who
is subsidizing these countries like Saudi Arabia,
Qatar.
We understand that.
I think it makes our job as westerners western last,
whatever's easiest.